now the financial impact of all this oil
has absolutely exploded in price i'll
explain in a second why that is the
russian stock market went down 50
percent
yesterday they literally just shut it
off and said we'll be back
at a time that we determine later just
like we're done trading u.s stocks
opened up down today bitcoin
is down gold is up about five percent
over the last 30 days
and people are looking around saying
what the hell is going on
so let's start first with gold gold's up
five percent over the last 30 days
and
a lot of folks are looking at that and
they're saying wow
people are looking at gold as kind of a
chaos edge
true to some degree
one of the things a lot of people don't
know though
is that
vladimir putin in russia and their
central bank have over 600 billion
dollars worth of foreign currencies in
gold
and what they're doing
is right now think of that as their
balance sheet that gold's going up in
value it's expanding in value now five
percent isn't a hundred percent but it's
still pretty material when you have
hundreds of billions of dollars
obviously that matters
and so in some way
russia
invading ukraine has increased the value
of the assets that they have in their
central bank
now russia previously
had their conflict with crimea
and we saw the same thing at that point
as well and now they've had a number of
years to go ahead and position
themselves they've swapped out assets
they've been a net seller of dollars
they've added gold reserves they've done
a bunch of different stuff over the last
two years to put themselves in this
position
now on top of this
is
oil
oil prices been high for the last two
years in america and internationally
those oil prices
you see in your electricity bill you see
it when you go and you pump gasoline
russia
is the third largest oil producer in the
world about 12 percent of oil of global
oil production comes from russia
17
of natural gas production
comes from russia
i think we've got a uh image that shows
that that natural gas
that comes from russia
flows through places like ukraine we've
got all the natural gas pipelines here
that you can see flowing through there
major pipelines that go to europe go to
asia as well on the other side
and so when you start to look at this
you say to yourself
what's the impact of oil going up
if you produce 12
of the oil production around the world
then you got to ask yourself
are you a net importer or a net exporter
of oil what that basically means is
does russia sell their oil or do they
consume it all themselves and obviously
the answer is they're a net exporter
they make a lot of money from oil
oil going over 100 per barrel means that
russia is actually profiting from this
situation
so what we're watching
is that
russia has put themselves in a position
where by invading ukraine their balance
sheet is expanding and it's not a u.s
dollar uh balance sheet in terms of the
us dollars getting more valuable it's
other assets
and also one of their largest revenue
sources in terms of oil and natural gas
prices are exploding and they're making
more money
now most people would say well why don't
we just stop buying the oil from russia
like that'd be a pretty quick way to
shut off their revenue
the problem is the united states is not
energy independent
we had a pipeline
that could get us all the oil we needed
got shut down
again i'm not gonna monday morning
quarterback that decision
a lot of people asking was that the
right decision now though
on top of that
the united states is actually the
largest oil producer in the world i
think we've got a graphic that shows the
united states here in yellow
versus the russian federation or saudi
arabia united states is number one
but the difference is
the united states may produce the most
oil
but the united states also is a massive
consumer of oil as well
and so the united states actually
consumes more oil than it produces which
means that the u.s
is a net consumer or a net importer of
oil we are dependent on other countries
for oil
russia on the other hand is a net
exporter they're able to satisfy their
energy needs and then they have
leftovers and they sell that and make
money from it and so ultimately the
united states and the citizens here in
this country they're taking it on the
chin
five dollar gasoline
per gallon
high energy bills
not looking good
it looks like it's only going to get
higher
the united states has asked russia and
saudi arabia to produce more oil to
flood the market with higher supply so
that more supply can lead to lower
prices
russia and saudi arabia said no
so we are beholden
to
russia and saudi arabia on an energy
production standpoint because we are a
net importer
russia is a net exporter
so when you start to look at this
it's a very very interesting situation
it's almost surreal to watch this
where a country
invaded ukraine is making more money
from a revenue standpoint their balance
sheet is expanding
the natural
thought process is that the united
states
and other allies nato etc will follow
through and they will levy financial
sanctions
whether it's on government officials
whether it is on the largest banks
whether it's on some combination or some
expansion of who they're actually going
to put these financial sanctions on
but the holy grail of financial
sanctions would be russia's removal from
the swift system
now of course
one of the
important details or nuances of
financial sanctions
is that those sanctions only work
if the country that you are sanctioning
or the individual or the company that
you're sanctioning uses that currency
the united states is the beneficiary of
being the producer and distributor of
the us dollar which is the global
reserve currency they've
gone around the world we've implemented
sanctions on countries that we disagree
with or that we think violate our view
of good and evil
many many many people would argue that
it was a positive thing the financial
sanctions avoided violent conflict saved
american lives and allowed us to punish
people who we felt like were violating
human rights
or some other issues that we had
but ultimately
if a country doesn't use u.s dollars
they don't have immense amounts of u.s
dollars on their central bank balance
sheet they have foreign currencies or
they have gold or they have some other
assets like bitcoin or something else
the sanctions have less bite
you can still levy them
people will still talk about it but you
may not actually have the intended
impact of shutting down their economy of
cutting them off from the global
financial system
and so russia and china specifically
have been talking about this literally
for years
that they want to get off the us dollar
system they think it's expensive they
think it's dangerous to be dependent on
a u.s dollar global reserve system
and part of the problem why they haven't
been able to do this historically
is because the international community
is unlikely to put their faith
at the level of a global reserve
currency
in rubles or rent and beat
and so ultimately what they've basically
been relegated to is talking a lot about
getting off the us dollar system but not
actually being able to do it
in recent months we've seen russia and
china start to talk a lot more about
bilateral trade
talk about having a deeper partnership
or relationship
and now there's a lot of people asking
the question
well if you can't actually control and
distribute the global reserve currency
in the way the united states does
will these countries look at gold or
bitcoin or some other asset
i personally think we're now at the
point where the united states must take
bitcoin seriously we must become the
global leader we must ensure that we own
as a country more bitcoin than any other
country in the world
that we have more hash rate than any
other country in the world
that we treat bitcoin as a traditional
currency we reduce the tax burden on
spending the asset
that we do everything we possibly can to
incentivize bitcoiners and those that
are supporting the network or building
for the network to move to the united
states create economic prosperity and
jobs
because ultimately even if you think
there's a 0.0001
chance
that the u.s dollar is not the global
reserve currency in 50 or 100 years you
think it's the most small insignificant
percentage chance
that's still a scenario that the united
states should be prepared for
and the first best option
if you are a
kind of
introspective
focused
person or country
is that you want to be the controller of
the global reserve currency you want to
produce it you want to distribute it you
want to be able to levy financial
sanctions etc
but the next best option is if you can't
do that whether you're china russia or
somewhere else and you say you know what
we can't actually be the producer or
distributor of the global reserve
currency or united states you say wow
there's a very small chance but a chance
that our currency ends up not being the
global reserve currency at some point in
the future the next best option
is to be the most advanced
largest holder
and biggest supporter
and largest market participant
in a global currency that no one
controls
if you can't control it the next best
option is that no one controls it
and that's ultimately where i think
we're headed i don't think it's in the
short term i think it's going to happen
over a long period of time but i do
think the united states needs to get
ahead of this and we need to position
ourselves to be successful in that
environment